you know what we ended season 5 on a
huge cliffhanger you want to find out
whether you know captain Holt becomes a
commissioner or not I promise you that
will be answered in the first episode we
will find out and then now that you know
Jake and Amy are married we're gonna see
where this relationship goes you know
what I'm saying and I'm ready for more
high jinks more stuff with the crew it's
just gonna be insane more more and
better all of us are really thrilled to
be on and you see I think we've always
had those roots in our show because they
produced our show in the Geico
I am personally really excited about
being able to say bad words and then
have them be bleeped out I think that's
just like yeah it just feels I'm it's
it's beyond I mean it was such a like
unexpected surprising outcome to that
whole two days and yeah like somebody
said they've always produced our show so
it's a bit of like going home in a sense
it's great we're so excited and they're
excited and everybody's excited
excitement of bounds the new season
holds many fun stories obviously we're
gonna pay off the cliffhanger with
captain Holt we're gonna find out
whether or not he got the big promotion
as commissioner we're gonna see what
married life holds for Jake and Amy
we're gonna see roses newfound love life
continue I'm sure we're gonna see
Charles and fashio waited with food and
being slightly weird but lovable it's
gonna be good we're excited there's a
lot of fun stories coming I would hope
that we would have some amazing guest
stars as well as the continuing foibles
of our squad nothing is everything it's
not broke we're not gonna fix it we're a
lot of the same
I think that NBC now allows us to like
you sleeps for like that's how we're
pushing here but like sometimes you just
kind of just you gotta say it I'm more
the same like we're really excited oh my
god you know it's weird because I'm a
comic-con vet
I've been here since like 2010 with the
Expendables and all three of them and
and then all the I hosted the Netflix
panel last year but to be back because
my show is now on NBC we're back to life
we back from the dead it's absolutely
amazing and we took a bus down here from
LA and it's been a party the whole time
I think their piano it's gonna be really
fun
yeah later I think that'll be really fun
our fans usually have really great some
weird cool questions during Q&A so I'm
just psyched for that and I heard there
was like a line for our panel there's
also and we're gonna do a giveaway of
like signed like scripts and DVDs and so
I think people are gonna be excited to
do that Brooklyn nine-nine tribute we
had a you know the kind of a sad last
day in season five weren't sure if we
were gonna get picked up and we're like
but even if we don't I'm sure maybe Hulu
and Netflix will do it and then when
that didn't happen there was this
feeling of wow this is really over this
is doing and then suddenly you know the
Twitter and social media went ballistic
and suddenly we were saved it was like
you know being brought back from the
dead like clearest at you amazing really
good we're ecstatic to have a new lease
on life you know we thought that we
weren't gonna be making the show anymore
and NBC saved us
like so many nights of the round table
because you know what the internet
brought this thing back the internet
loves Brooklyn nine-nine and the
internet runs Comic Con I mean this is
where the buzz happens this is where you
find out who's who what's what what's
cool over the next year and it's all
about blogging it's all about putting
this stuff down and you know it's about
the Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
and this is what it is and it's funny
how I saw someone cosplay me as Terry
Jeffords with the suspenders and Ty and
I retweeted it I'm going only at
comic-con it's incredible we didn't
think we'd be around let alone at
comic-con so we're thrilled we're
thrilled with the outpouring of love and
support we've had from our
thank you very much I mean just just the
outpouring the unapologetic fandom here
is the best I was a nerd when other
kiddos and Stephen King and horror
comics and and I was as passionate as
many everyone here is about their
particular show so I feel at home it's
incredible I mean we've done promotion
for the show before over the last few
seasons but this is out of this world I
didn't know how huge
I mean I'd read about it I heard about
it but I just thought it was kind of
like in one building or something oh my
god comic-con has taken over the whole
city it's amazing we had no idea well we
met the people from dr. know Doctor Who
Doctor Who doctor know who who knows but
here's the deal we're both huge fans of
a show called broadchurch in which the
people who are behind this show are all
and we were we were both like oh my god
we love you and this is what's cool they
said we love Brooklyn 99 it's so good so
it was really great I actually said to
her I can Amanda yeah here I go stepping
right into it some more I said oh I'm so
excited for your role in dr. no but I
was thinking about broad shirts I felt
like a big dummy but then you planted
the seed we don't know we haven't read a
script yet but I'm assuming it's gonna
be very good I don't think it'll be
dramatically different if it's different
at all I'm not sure I haven't we have
not seen a script we don't know Dan and
gore and his guys are in Andy they're
all putting it together at this point
they're a little tight-lipped we'll have
our first table read on the 8th of
August oh yeah and then we'll then we'll
know a little more but NBC is its old
home for me I mean my dad was on NBC
forever
and I was on NBC for a few years years
before you were born I imagine but at
any rate so we're I'm thrilled to be
back and and we're just thrilled to
we're thrilled to be moving on fantastic
we've been welcomed with open arms yes
we have but we're very happy 10 out of
10 10 out of 10 percent
you